Transcription: Hazel Koh
Relecteur: eric vautier
(Musique)
(Fin de la musique)
Je ne joue pas un morceau. J'improvise.
J’essaie des notes. Ce n'est pas parfait.
Peu importe. Je cherche.
(Musique)
(Fin de la musique)
J'essaie. J'essaie.
(Applaudissements)
Peu importe que ce soit parfait,
je travaille, je m'amuse un peu.
Je joue, je cherche,
parce que je suis un chercheur.
Mon métier, mon domaine de recherche,
c'est la chirurgie
assistée par ordinateur.
Je travaille avec des chirurgiens.
Je ne suis pas un chirurgien moi-même.
Là, c'est moi avec un bonnet bleu.
Vous avez vu ? J'aime bien les bonnets.
Bref, qu'importe.
Je travaille avec des chirurgiens,
mais je ne suis pas un chirurgien.
Mon domaine, mes compétences -
que j'ai appris à l'école -
sont les mathématiques,
la physique et l'informatique.
Je ne suis pas un crack
dans ces domaines non plus,
mais j'arrive à m’exprimer avec.
Alors, vous allez me demander
comment je peux être
Directeur de Recherche
à l’Institut National pour
la Santé Et la Recherche Médicale
et Président de la société
scientifique internationale
de chirurgie assistée par ordinateur.
Je vais vous l'expliquer.
(Applaudissements)
C'est simple. C'est simple.
J'ai une méthode, la mienne.
C'est juste la mienne.
D'abord, j'aime découvrir.
J'aime essayer.
J'aime apprendre, comprendre.
Je suis patient.
J'essaie. J'essaie encore et encore.
Je ne travaille pas tout seul.
Je travaille avec des gens,
avec beaucoup de gens, en réseau.
Je vais chercher
les compétences un peu partout.
J'essaie dans tous les domaines.
Vous allez voir.
J'essaie partout, mais partout.
Et je donne. Je donne beaucoup.
Je donne beaucoup. Je donne des idées.
Je donne mes idées.
Je donne des émotions.
Et puis, je n'ai pas peur.
Pas peur. Même pas peur. Même pas mal.
Même si j'ai peur, je fais quand même,
parce que parfois j'ai peur.
J'ai peur de rater. J'ai peur d’hésiter.
J'ai peur de mal jouer.
Mais je fais quand même.
Alors, je vais vous présenter un petit peu
tout ça dans les minutes qui vont suivre,
avec quelques exemples.
Suivez-moi.
Je suis, dans mon métier de chercheur,
confronté à des problèmes comme celui-là.
Je vous présente Éric.
Éric, c'est un patient qui a une dystonie.
La dystonie, c'est une maladie
neurologique à trouble moteur.
C'est comme la maladie de Parkinson.
Sauf que la dystonie, ce sont des
contractions musculaires involontaires.
Il y a une trentaine d'années environ,
un neurochirurgien français
a inventé une technique
qui s'appelle la stimulation
cérébrale profonde
et qui consiste à insérer dans le cerveau
du patient de toutes petites électrodes,
à l’intérieur du cerveau,
et qui vont aller stimuler électriquement
deux petites structures.
Et en les stimulant en continu,
électriquement, tout le temps, ça marche.
On voit Éric trois ans après,
il a grandi, il a changé,
et ses troubles moteurs ont disparu.
Éric n'est pas guéri, mais ses troubles
moteurs ont disparu par la stimulation.
Comme le cerveau est un peu complexe,
quand on stimule à un endroit,
on stimule un petit peu partout autour.
Comme les neurochirurgiens
et les neurologues
ne sont pas complètement
d'accord sur l'endroit -
il n'y a pas un consensus
exact sur l'endroit où il faut stimuler -
et que probablement, il faut stimuler
des zones différentes pour chaque patient,
il y a chez certains patients
des effets secondaires négatifs.
Des troubles de l'émotion, de l’apathie,
et parfois même, l'apparition d'addictions
comme l'addiction au jeu.
Les personnes n'avaient pas
d’addictions avant
et puis, avec la stimulation,
acquièrent une addiction.
C'est là que moi j’interviens.
C'est là qu'en tant que chercheur
commence mon travail.
Alors, comment je fais ?
Je vais d'abord aller chercher
mes compétences de base
en mathématiques, physique, informatique,
puis celles de mes collègues,
les super chercheuses, super chercheurs,
super étudiantes, super étudiants
qui travaillent avec moi,
et qui ont, entre parenthèses,
très souvent des compétences qui sont
supérieures aux miennes, peu importe.
Je vais les chercher,
on travaille ensemble,
puis, on essaie, par exemple,
on développe des méthodes qui,
à partir des images médicales du patient,
permettent de construire un cerveau
virtuel 3D de chaque patient
sur lequel la neurochirurgienne à Rennes,
qui fait ces opérations,
peut préparer son insertion d’électrodes
pour essayer d'être la plus sûre possible.
En plus, pour essayer de prédire
ces effets secondaires négatifs
qui peuvent arriver
chez certains patients,
on va collecter
toutes les données des patients,
avant la stimulation,
après la stimulation,
et on va aller étudier ces données
pour essayer de voir les cas qui marchent
et les cas qui ne marchent pas.
On utilise des méthodes comme
l'intelligence artificielle, par exemple,
qui nous permet de prédire,
pour ces certains patients,
le fait que la procédure
ne va pas très bien marcher
ou qu'il faut faire attention
parce qu'il y a des effets secondaires
qui risquent d’apparaître.
Et la neurochirurgienne nous dit :
« Ça marche, ça marche.
La durée des interventions
est plus courte.
Les effets secondaires
sur les patients sont réduits.
Et il n'y a quasiment plus d'infections. »
Alors, là, je suis content.
Ce n'est pas toujours comme ça,
mais là, je suis vraiment content.
C'est une recherche qui a abouti.
Alors on va un petit peu plus loin.
Cette neurochirurgienne,
on aimerait savoir
comment elle opère exactement,
comment elle fait,
quel instrument chirurgical elle utilise,
combien de temps, avec quelle séquence.
Alors, on cherche des méthodes
qui par observation -
on va l'observer en salle d'op,
on va regarder ce qu'elle fait -
et puis, par observation,
on va analyser sa pratique
et on va en extraire des graphes,
des modèles qui expriment son métier.
Ils peuvent nous servir, par exemple,
appliqués sur les infirmières
de bloc opératoire
qu'on va, elles aussi, observer,
ils peuvent nous servir
pour construire des environnements
de réalité virtuelle
qui permettent à ces infirmières
de bloc opératoire de s’entraîner.
On continue la progression,
on continue les projets de recherche.
Aujourd’hui, on commence -
je dis on, le laboratoire commence -
avec moi un projet de recherche...
N'en parlez pas trop parce que je
n'ai pas publié encore là-dessus,
et donc ça reste entre nous, hein ?
C'est un projet de recherche
où on va étudier l'activité cérébrale
du chirurgien pendant qu'il opère -
pas pendant qu'il opère parce que ça va le
déranger, mais pendant qu'il s'entraîne.
On va mesurer l'activité électrique
de son cerveau pendant qu'il travaille.
Avec comme objectif derrière
d'essayer d’identifier la courbe
de progression des chirurgiens,
comment il réagit au stress,
comment il réagit
à un événement inattendu.
Et, on pense qu'on peut impacter comme ça
la progression
et l’apprentissage du chirurgien.
« Et après ? » vous allez me dire,
« après, Pierre, tu vas faire quoi ?
Dans cinq ans, dans dix ans,
où tu vas te retrouver ?
Qu'est-ce que vont être les idées ?
Comment élargir ce champ de créativité ?
Comment trouver,
comment ouvrir des portes ? »
Là aussi, j'ai ma méthode.
Très simple.
Je cherche partout.
Mais alors, partout.
J'essaie partout.
Partout, ça veut dire
d'abord à l’étranger.
Je voyage, je voyage beaucoup.
Je vais aux États-Unis, au Canada,
en Norvège, en Allemagne, au Japon.
Je travaille avec Makoto,
qui est un chirurgien japonais,
et on étudie ensemble
les différences de pratique
entre les infirmières de
bloc opératoire françaises
et les infirmières de
bloc opératoire japonaises.
Je vois si les méthodes que je développe
à Rennes peuvent être utilisées au Japon,
aux États-Unis, au Canada.
J'essaie partout.
Quand je vous dis partout, c'est partout.
C'est aussi dans tous les domaines.
Je travaille avec des
mathématiciens, informaticiens,
physiciens, chirurgiens, neurologues,
mais aussi avec un professeur
de management en entreprise,
avec un professeur de design
à l'école des Beaux-Arts de Strasbourg.
Et puis, j'ai essayé avec des acteurs,
avec un guitariste de rock,
avec des plasticiens, avec...
Un exemple :
les plasticiens.
Il y a trois ou quatre ans,
j'ai rencontré Fred et Flavien,
qui sont deux plasticiens
qui font des installations numériques.
Moi, j'avais envie de comprendre
comment eux font pour travailler,
quelle est leur démarche créative.
Et je voulais utiliser
cette démarche créative
pour améliorer
cette représentation 3D du cerveau.
Cette répresentation est un peu complexe
et je voulais faire en sorte que
leur méthode permette de la simplifier
et permette de transmettre
plus d'information au chirurgien.
On s'est vus 1, 2, 3, 4 fois,
on a fait plein de réunions.
J'ai présenté ce que je faisais,
eux ce qu'ils faisaient.
On a discuté énormément, énormément.
On n'est arrivé à rien.
Ça n'a pas marché, mais alors,
pas du tout, pas du tout.
Bon, ça arrive.
C'est la recherche : on essaie,
des fois, ça ne marche pas.
Il y a -
Un autre exemple.
Il y a un mois environ,
un mois et demi,
la neurochirurgienne
avec qui je travaille,
qui s'occupe aussi
de la chirurgie de l’épilepsie -
Cette chirurgie, c'est un peu particulier,
c'est dans le cas de patients
épileptiques sévères
qui ont beaucoup de crises
d’épilepsie par jour.
La seule solution si les médicaments
ne marchent plus
est d'aller enlever par chirurgie
la petite zone cérébrale
qui est au départ de crises d’épilepsie.
La neurochirurgienne un jour
arrive dans mon bureau :
(Toc toc toc)
« Bonjour Pierre.
J'avais une idée : j'aimerais
bien entendre la crise d’épilepsie.
J'aimerais bien l'entendre
pour voir où elle démarre. »
Moi, vous parlez d'entendre ;
entendre, je pense musique.
(Bruits électroniques)
Deux, trois jours avant,
j'avais rencontré Jesse.
Jesse, c'est un musicien
qui fait de la musique électronique :
« Jesse, je te donne les signaux
enregistrés sur des patients épileptiques,
transforme-les-moi en musique. »
Ce que vous entendez, c'est les premiers
résultats qu'il m'a envoyés juste mardi.
(Musique électronique)
J'essaie, vous avez vu.
J'essaie. Je cherche.
Je me trompe. Je réussis.
C'est la recherche.
Ici, même là avec vous, en ce moment,
là sur la scène, je cherche aussi.
Je suis aussi dans
mon approche de chercheur.
Je donne. Je communique. Je donne.
Les rares fois où il m'est arrivé d'être
sur une scène, comme là, en concert,
j'ai senti qu'il fallait donner.
Il faut tout donner.
Qu'on reçoive ou pas, peu importe, c'est
la base, c'est la condition nécessaire.
Donc, ici aussi, je vous donne.
Je m'amuse aussi, vous avez vu ?
Et je travaille.
Et je vais apprendre, je vais découvrir.
Comme vous, je rencontre.
Vous aussi aujourd’hui,
vous apprenez, découvrez, rencontrez.
Vous êtes aussi dans une démarche
de chercheur aujourd'hui.
Comme moi, vous êtes des chercheurs
pour une vie meilleure,
la nôtre
et celle des autres.
Ma question, c'est : « Et vous,
c'est quoi, votre méthode ? »
(Applaudissements)
(Guitare)
Et l'ours dit oui,
l'ours dit toujours oui.
Et les gens crient,
les gens crient aujourd'hui.
Les gens crient beaucoup aujourd'hui.
Et Madame Turpin a faim.
Qu'apporte cette séquence au pot
commun ? et l'absence prend l'eau.
Mettre au moins la démence au chaud
Mais Madame Turpin a faim.
C'est pas facile d'être immobile.
C'est pas si facile de rester sur un fil.
Mais qu'importe ces vagues de drogues,
Vomir à la porte de l'église.
Synagogue apporte un sens à la glisse.
Ouvrez, ouvrez, Madame Turpin a faim.
C'est pas facile d'être immobile.
C'est pas si facile de rester sur un fil.
Ouvrez, ouvrez à l'ours.
Prélevez-vous mes frères du sang.
Artères amères vides de sens
Attention, Madame Turpin a faim.
C'est pas facile d'être immobile.
C'est pas si facile de rester sur un fil.
(Fin de la musique)
(Applaudissements)